- Do you know what a Jell-O shot is?
- A Jell-O shot?
- Yeah.
- Is it like some kind of injection?
- We are here at the
Golden Globes red carpet
and we're going to play Jell-O...
- Or Jell-O shot.
- [Voiceover] I also want
to see how they eat Jell-O.
Are they the finger people
or the tongue people?
I'm a tonguer.
Obviously tonight is the
biggest party in Hollywood.
No party is complete without...
- [Both] Jell-O shots.
- (chuckles) Okay.
- [Sir Patrick] Okay. Jell-O.
- Well...
- [Sir Patrick] No.
- So, it's Jell-O but some
of it has booze in it.
- [Sir Patrick] Oh, really?
- I want you to pick one
for you and one for me.
- That one's yours and that one's mine.
- This is Jell-O and that's a shot.
- Great.
- Do we have to take them?
- [Both] Yeah.
- Oh, I don't eat Jell-O.
But I'll pick one for you.
- Do you have any strategies
in taking Jell-O shots?
- No, usually I take
them off of people's tits
but I guess tonight
I'm doing it on my own.
- The best strategy is to
loosen it up with your finger
because it's going to be hard to suck out.
- [Sir Patrick] Really?
- Yeah.
- Hold on.
- Oh, I'm sorry. (chuckles)
I love Jell-O.
- Cheers.
(women chanting)
- Oh!
- [Woman Interviewer] There we go.
- What is...
Is that moonshine?
(woman chanting)
- This will be alcohol. Whoa.
- You just tongued that Jell-O shot.
- There we go.
What are your thoughts?
- Jell-O.
All that and no alcohol.
- Nope, I have no booze.
Thanks for nothing.
- Oh that's just straight up Jell-O, yeah.
That's a shot.
- All in one. All in one.
- That is disgusting.
- I thought the moisture
would be the liquor.
I thought that my science grade...
Third grade science grade... (laughs)
- Drunk already.
- We are halfway through this red carpet
and I have had a lot of Jell-O shots.
This is Hollywood's biggest party.
Yeah! Yeah!
You did an okay job.
- I'm usually much better
with my mouth than this.
- Whoa!
(acts drunk)
- I just feel so bad for you right now.
- I feel good.
I feel so good for me.
One last thing, are there
any confessions you can make?
Anything weird you've ever
done before a red carpet?
- Yeah, this morning I shaved my pubes.
I wanted to feel special.
- Is that all? Nothing else?
- No. No, what do you want to talk about?
- [Sir Patrick] No.
- How's your day going?
- It's great.
Let's hope it gets better.
This guy is following me around
and I don't know who he is.
It's no longer fun.
- And it gets personal.
That's what I don't like about it.
- Of course it gets personal...
I don't know what his name is...
- I'm in an interview right now.
- Oh, is that what you call it?
(giggles)
- [Woman Interviewer] What the
hell is going on? (giggles)